il ya des ruptures technologiques
majeures dans l' architecture de la 5g
je vous en donne deux l'advanced sound
flipmode qui fait que entre deux
émissions de paquets de données ce
fonctionne par paquet on est capable de
couper les équipements il ya certains
travaux qui sont des travaux
indépendants de recherche qui parle
d'une économie possible sur les
équipements sur les bts sur l'image que
vous avez derrière vous qui serait de
jusqu'à 60 %
c'est pas notre c'est extrêmement
significatif et puis le deuxième c'est
les antennes les antennes qu'on est
caractéristique qui sont totalement
nouvelles par rapport à ce qu'elle avait
auparavant l'une d'entre elles c'est
d'être directionnelle ce qui fait que
auparavant vous aviez des abat-jour qui
envoient entre guillemets des ondes dans
toutes les directions pour attraper le
mobile où qu'ils soient
maintenant c'est plutôt des lampes de
poche vous éclairer dans la direction du
mobile et donc vous en voyez beaucoup
beaucoup moins d'énergie vous consommez
moins vous rayonnez - et puis ces
antennes elles sont aussi appropriée au
contexte dans lequel elles se trouvent
si vous êtes dans un contexte à très
haute densité
on va mettre ce qu'on appelle des nano
celle les petites antennes en très grand
nombre qui permettra d'envoyer une
petite quantité d'énergie pour rejoindre
le mobile avec une bande de fréquences
qui sera approprié à ce type d' usage et
mine de rien c'est une rupture très
forte celle que quand on a fait la 4g on
n'a pas pensé comme ça ni la 3g d'air on
a pensé à peu près sûr l'achitecture qui
préexistait depuis l'émergence des
réseaux cellulaires et ça je crois que
ça mérite d'être dit pas ce que ça va
pas apparaître dans les mois qui vont
venir
mais à moyen terme ça à voir ça va avoir
un impact extrêmement conséquent sur les
réseaux je ne vous garantirais pas que
ça va réduire la consommation d'énergie
mais je dirais que c'est par honnêteté
et c'est pas du tout exclu que c'est la
région la réduisent de façon extrêmement
significative
[Musique]